all right we're going to look at
something fascinating today this is the
best confrontational interview that
Donald Trump has ever done and you are
going to see stevenskeep from NPR
dismantle each lie that Trump tells and
you will see firsthand what happens when
a real interviewer is placed in a
position where he or she can actually
counteract Trump's lies this interview
that I'm going to play for you here this
is a slow-moving train wreck the
Jonathan Swann interview on axios with
Trump where Trump held up maps and
charts and said but you can't do that
sir that was like a rapid train wreck
this is a slow-moving train wreck where
each claim trumps make each claim Trump
makes is refuted with fact by
stevenskeep and eventually Trump just
hangs up the phone Trump aborts the
interview because it is going so poorly
each time he's confronted he moves on to
another topic I'm going to keep track of
all the different claims so that then we
can actually add them up beautifully
done by Stevens keep Let's Just Jump
Right In just have to point out Doug
Logan to name one of the states that you
just named Doug Logan who ran the audit
in Arizona that was set up by your
allies didn't find serious problems this
is a quote the ballots that were
provided to us to count in the Coliseum
very accurately correlate with the
official canvas numbers he raised a
bunch of administrative issues but
didn't find a problem that would have
changed the result at all the ballots
May correspond but look at the ballots
themselves the number of ballots doesn't
mean anything it's who signed the
ballots where did the ballots come from
what you really have to do in that
report is look at the findings and the
findings are devastating for Arizona
they're devastating like nobody's seen
before
just as bad why did Republican officials
in Arizona accept the results then
because they're rhinos and frankly a lot
of people are questioning that why would
they they fought very hard the Maricopa
County that's claim too don't worry I'm
keeping track and then we'll review this
is this is Fascinating People and people
don't understand it because all you have
to do is look at the findings and just
so you know some of those people went
before Congress uh a short while ago and
they were grilled by uh if Congressman
Biggs you ought to take a look at their
testimony they weren't able to answer
anything he made them look like fools
they couldn't answer a thing they got up
and gave a beautiful statement and then
when it came time to ask why this why
that what about these votes what about
those votes they look like total fools
let me uh read you some short quotes the
first is by one of the judges one of the
ten judges you appointed who ruled on
this and there were many judges but ten
who you appointed Brett Ludwig U.S
District Court in Wisconsin who was
nominated by you in 2020 he's on the
bench and he says quote this court
allowed the plaintiff the chance to make
his case and he has lost on the merits
another quote Corey langhofer your own
campaign attorney in Arizona November 12
2020 quote we are not alleging fraud in
this lawsuit we are not alleging anyone
stealing the election and also Rudy
Giuliani your lawyer November 18 2020 in
Pennsylvania quote this is not a fraud
case your own lawyers had no evidence of
fraud they said in court they had no
evidence and the judges ruled against
you every time on the merits it was too
early to ask for fraud and to talk about
fraud Rudy said that because of the fact
it was very early with the because that
was obviously at a very very that was a
long time ago the things that have found
out have more than bore out what people
thought and what people felt and what
people found when you look at langhafer
I disagree with him as an attorney I did
not think he was a good attorney to hire
I don't know what his game is but I will
just say this you look at the findings
you look at the number of votes go into
Detroit and just ask yourself is it true
that there are more votes than there are
voters look at Pennsylvania look at
Philadelphia is it true that there were
far more votes than there were voters it
is not true
it is not a pretty tough problem it is
not true that there were far more votes
than voters there was an early count
I've noticed you've talked about this in
rallies and you've said reportedly this
is true I think even you know that that
was an early report that was corrected
later well you take a look at it really
take a look at Detroit and fact they
even had a hard time getting people to
sign off on it because it was so out of
balance they called it out of balance so
you take a look at it you know the real
truth Steve and if this election was a
rigged election why is it that you think
that the vast majority of your allies in
the United States Senate are not
standing behind you we did have that
statement by Mike rounds because Mitch
McConnell is a little
Mitch McConnell if he were on the other
side and if Schumer were put in his
position he would have been fighting
this like you've never seen before he
would have been fighting this I hope you
guys are taking notes like I am because
when you look at it and this is long is
a long way from over you take a look at
what's going on now in Pennsylvania take
a look at what's going on in Wisconsin
you just take a look now we had a lot of
cases where the judges wouldn't hear
them we had a case in Nevada that was so
good will you read the papers it's
impossible the judge refused to even
listen to it we had many cases in fact
they say and I can't testify because
it's been through a lot of systems a lot
of different systems but they say and
they say very strongly the judge is just
nobody's really gotten the chance so
look look at the United States Supreme
Court they refuse to hear the case and
you had they said there was no standing
to get the case that's correct I know no
standing and the president of the United
States supposedly didn't have standing
either so I wanted to file it myself
they said sir you don't have standing I
said so yeah I mean that's true you know
if he is not a Pennsylvania voter he's
not a Wisconsin voter okay we don't need
to even focus on that now in a second
Trump hangs up because he's just sick of
this wait a minute I'm the president
they just rigged an election hundreds of
thousands of votes in different states
they just rigged an election we got we
got a number of votes that I think
you'll agree no sitting president has
ever gotten a number of votes that I got
no support that's true
sitting president do you nobody believes
do you think Biden got 80 million votes
I don't believe it's true that you've
got more than anything president in the
election that disputed how come he
couldn't Mr President Mr President let
me ask you this question how come Biden
couldn't have direct 20 people for a
credit how come when he went to speak in
different locations nobody came to watch
but all of a sudden he got 80 million
votes nobody believes you're forgiving
maybe because the election was about you
if I can just move on to ask are you
telling Republicans in 2022 that they
must press your case on the past
election in order to get right they're
going to do whatever they want to do
whatever they have to do they're going
to do but the ones that are smart the
ones that know you take a look at again
you take a look at how Carrie lake is
doing running for governor she's very
big on this issue she's leading by a lot
people have no idea how big this issue
is and they don't want it to happen
again it shouldn't be allowed to happen
and they don't want it to happen again
the only way it's not going to happen
again is you have to solve the problem
of the presidential rigged election of
2020. Mr President thank you very much
one more question I want to ask about a
court hearing yesterday
let's judge a meat
um you know when uh he sort of like
Withers away you know if what happens if
you take cotton candy and you put it
under water
um that's what happens to Trump under
questioning he it just there's nothing
there
fantastically done by stevenskeep read
through how every argument Trump makes
falls apart and he just moves to the
next one
um Stevens keep says they looked at all
they looked at the ballots the ballots
are fine the counts were fine and Trump
says well the number of ballots were
fine but if you looked individually the
ballots have bogus signatures or they
are invalid in some other way so that's
the shifting that's so it's no longer
about the numbers but now it's about
each individual ballot
Stevens keep says the Republican Party
accepted the results and he says those
aren't really Republicans he says those
are rhinos so that's the next argument
Stevens keep says lawyers your lawyers
and judges you appointed say it's fine
and that it is not there there is no
fraud and Trump says the lawyers were
bad and at that time it was too early to
claim fraud
it was true that of course then the
fraud had to be claimed later
but Stevens keep says Pennsylvania and
Detroit uh Trump says in Pennsylvania
and Detroit there were more votes than
voters
that's just completely untrue and
stevenskeep knows that you can look it
up yourself it's it's public there were
not more votes than voters
um then
Stevens keep asks why are your
Republican colleagues in the Senate not
standing up for this
and he says well Mitch McConnell's a
loser wow okay Trump says it's not over
in Pennsylvania and Wisconsin there's
still things happening no there aren't
Trump says courts haven't actually
looked at the cases that's a lie 63
cases were looked at and dismissed
Trump says hundreds of thousands of
votes were rigged so he's kind of going
back to the votes again uh and then he
says how did Biden get 80 million votes
if no one went to his events and of
course Biden was being really cautious
at the time because of covet and wasn't
really doing large events so piece by
piece you have nothing it evaporates
like cotton candy when put under water
you you just have grains of sand there
nothing substantial of any of any kind
excellent job by stevenskeep
one of our long time sponsors is monk
pack giving you 20 off monk packs keto
nut and Seed bars which taste just like
your favorite sweet snacks but without
the guilt because they have only one
gram of sugar two to three net carbs and
150 calories a great snack if you're
doing keto if you're doing low carb and
if you just want a low sugar snack I
love the monk pack nut and Seed bars
great balance of sweet and salty
satisfyingly crunchy soft and chewy
because I like these so much I use monk
Pack's subscription feature sends them
straight to my house on a regular basis
and saves me 10 if you don't love monk
pack as much as I do they will refund
you all your money I think there's a
really good chance monk pack nut and
Seed bars become your favorite go-to
snack monk pack is giving you 20 off
your first order go to monkpak.com and
enter the code Pacman at checkout